i enjoy going into a costume room and
then just being rails and rails of
deliciously expensive designer clothes
that i keep my eye on for the costume
sale when you get to the point where
it's a sort of series and presumably
you're not shooting chronologically and
you're shooting all over the world
and you know jumping from location to
location is there ever a sense
that you're on any kind of treadmill do
you get you know
or do you always get that kind of sense
of focus at the point when there's
somebody says action
yeah absolutely um it's always there and
i think what's wonderful about killing
eve is
a lot of the crew come back every year
like there's a real
i want to say well it is it's like you
know it's like a family unit in a way
and
people want to come back and they want
to carry this story on and
they're very passionate about what it is
that they're making and you can really
feel that and
you know they're very supportive and
respected of the things that you have to
do on set on any you know
given particular day or what you may
need on that day
um and exactly what glenda says is you
you you feel that everybody there
is wanting to do their absolute best and
i think that is so infectious
and it also makes you want to bring
a game and and be the best that you can
possibly be so
no i don't think that ever goes i don't
think you recognize that
um having done lots of series where
you're you're
you know working with the same character
over a long period of time
um i was just picking up on something
glenda said about rehearsal you do
we have the luxury of rehearsal but it's
really important to us because
um in the same way as villanelle i guess
like there's so many like i'm playing a
very highly intelligent woman
who um is hiding a lot and
she is um an orator and she
like i'm i i'm like oh my when i got it
i was like oh no i have to be this
intelligent
on screen that's a lot of work that goes
in and when i
watch you jody i always think that's a
lot of work before you get to
where you get to even with like natural
talent you've still got to put all that
work in so
um we do rehearse lots of scenes so that
we have the
luxury of then letting the magic happen
and i've never had i've never had that
before so that's
that's really nice um but yeah i
uh i mean it
i always get the buzz of you know and
action because you're just like ah
and now it's got now it has to come but
um
i love it i i just i think gentleman
jack's just a very different
beast than that you know i haven't
worked on anything
um this tough before the amount of lines
you work monday to friday you finish on
friday night i will come home and spend
some time with my four-year-old
and then on sunday i might have
breakfast and then get into
learning lines again for the next week
and it's it's tough it's a seven
month seven and a half month shoot so
it's a lot did you what i loved about
your performance
particularly as well was the way you
kind of embodied hair and your movement
i thought was so
specific and something that i enjoyed
watching was was
movement something that you did a lot of
before you got to set
yeah in the diversity so it described
her
as having a certain walk at a certain
gate
and wow people thought she looked like a
man and her voice was deep
and so there was loads of clues in the
diaries
um so we played around sally had me
walking around rehearsal rooms watching
me and
um and it was that bit was fun because
yeah and goes back to how to push it
because
i thought i was doing loads but once you
get the
the cravats and the coats and then the
top hat is massive i mean
it comes like it's so huge i had it here
the other day and i was like is it
really that big
yes it has the hat um and it feels
really odd
um i i guess with your character as well
and
possibly glenda when you were doing
those kind of outbursts
you feel like you're we're all so used
to doing
delicate um yeah pieces and the camera
you know and being subtle so when you
have to do
something big it can feel
odd but then when you accept it it's
the best thing ever because then yeah to
have fun but there is a moment where you
have to go from
subtlety to going really really oh okay
now this feels good
and then you can play presumably that's
exactly the same for both
of you though because you know it was
glenda you you sort of had to age up
and you know become sort of frail and
yet
um i mean one of the
the interesting things about film
whether you know it's from film well
they're all
campers now aren't they um is that you
do it in such small pieces
so the trick is is really
hanging on to the energy i mean
expanding it but then
if there's a hole hoping it's going to
fill up again because it's very rare
to actually shoot in sequence i don't
know how it is for you to
doing your series but i mean certainly
i remember when i was doing elizabeth
art we rarely have ever shot in sequence
and i invariably had around the man on
the
gate into white city because he would
never let me park my car there general i
mean so that was an endless
run but it it
what am i actually trying to say here
there is something about
being on a set and it is infinitely more
help it is infinitely helpful when as
jody said you know the same people were
working on it
so there are familiar faces and you know
who they are and they know who you are
they treat you like dirt and that's
perfectly okay because that's the whole
you know that's the basis of working
anyway
um and i think that makes it possible to
move
from you know things that need to be
subtle
the things that need to be unsubtle
because there is that
all the time you're actually when you're
lucky
i mean on this kind of river that is
flowing sometimes it may be
really so flown backwards but in fact
you're all there
in the same kind of situation on the
scene because
i think as well like as a society as
people we're all so
self-aware and when you're playing these
especially these particular characters
you
have to shed that you have to shed all
of that from yourself
and and then once you do that i think
it's so liberating
um but it is it's that it's that kind of
self-consciousness that you have to
get rid of um you touched on it a little
bit
um surrounded by talking about the the
hat and the cravat but
i think um costumes in all three cases
are really interesting to talk about
here there's
there's you with i mean you're the
opening credits of gentleman jack
they're it's it's like she's the
superhero sort of putting her costume
on it's so good yeah but i mean how
how how did that kind of impact on the
performance so you know like
you did you have a particular way of
dressing did you did you talk about the
the costumes you were going to have
before you were presented with it yeah
tom pye is i'm predominantly a theater
um
designer i'm um he's done some um
tv before but um he does operas
and and i and i loved that
that went on to our screen because you
know with sally's writing with the
character
with the with the sets and then with
these um i mean i've got quite big
shoulders today but i mean the women's
shoulders are like
you know like you can't even get on the
screen sometimes and
um and he invited me to be
right at the beginning of the process
with him and we went to cos props
and we had the male team and the female
team and we pushed it as far as we could
with the male
costumes and we took pictures and then
we'd add a little bit of
femininity in and then we'd take it away
and and he had all these references
um lots of um parisian references
of the time of you know who was pushing
it um
actually women on horseback kind of
dressed a little bit like gentleman jack
dresses so she can get away with still
dressing feminine if she was going
riding
but she's not um and and not you know
and kind of being
out in society and and
challenging gender like kind of like
hiding in plain sight with her dress
so it was it was all fascinating all
useful and
a lot of the costumes were made for me
um
by john at cost props and yeah i mean
what a delight to
to have that and again for the next
series they're making
some amazing stuff so i i just think our
team is
is just brilliant beyond
[Music]
same for you jody i mean villanelle's
costumes kind of transcended the show
actually
there was a bafta exhibition while the
bafta main premises was closed and the
one thing everybody went for was
villanelle's dress which was one of the
prize exhibits
um how did the you know what kind of
conversations did you have about the
wardrobe and how does that wardrobe
enable you
enable you as a character yeah well for
me what i love
witnessing is the um the playfulness
that the costume designers find when
they get this opportunity you know
especially some who who came up
for season three and the way they kind
of see that as a playground and there's
no kind of rules of
of wrong or right i just push that all
to them and
i enjoy going into a costume room and
then just being rails and rails of
deliciously expensive designer clothes
that i keep my eye on for the costume
sale um
but i honestly i kind of love just
giving them the reins to
to have fun with it and then for me it's
all about trying it on and
a big thing for villanelle is yes it's
fashion but it's got to be comfortable
it's got to be practical
and you know and i remember you know
talking to phoebe early on it's like
she's not going to scale the wall in six
inch heels like okay that's a
it happens in hollywood but it's not
gonna happen here you know what would
she be wearing so that she can do
what she needs to do um so it's always a
huge you know it's always so much fun
when i get to
to see what they've picked out and then
talking of practical and comfortable
maude's outfits for um costumes
um for elizabeth oh i mean
in a way that's where that's where kind
of um uh costume designers are kind of
unsung when they produce
the out the wardrobe to give you a
character
like maude how much were you presented
with that
that co those shoes and how much did you
um contribute my one guiding principle
um was that everything she wore must
look as though she'd
worn it for a long time that's the thing
that i can't
stand when you see people you know
supposedly in whatever the character is
and
they've obviously never worn that
whatever they're wearing before and so
that was
a big you know plus i mean it's easy to
get clothes and and to make them look as
though you've worn them a lot and that
was my big
driver but i remember when i was doing
elizabeth r
which was the we would rehearse and then
we'd have to go back to white city as it
was in the old days for costume fittings
and things like that
and it was a costume fitting for me
um for my sister mary's
at the coronational wedding i can't
remember which it was and so the dress
was white
glorious and the people who made it were
absolutely brilliant
and i'm not good at standing upright for
any length of time
and i passed out i was on the floor and
i came to
and i heard the voices of the costume
designer saying
don't get any blood on that dress don't
put any blood on that dress because i of
course have been pinned into
[Laughter]
and and it's the amount of times that
you're literally like
i just and and not or anything just to
just to keep me going because it's
exhausting just to not
all dude yeah you can you leave those
sessions like
because you are just stood there letting
people work and and
play with your face play with your hair
play with play with you
and those are the days that you go what
if i haven't done anything today but i'm
absolutely
exhausted exactly
i wanted to film in italy and
it was a costume fitting and the
designer was there this
middle-aged gentleman deltori as they're
according
and these three absolutely dedicated
women who made the costumes
and i'm standing there and he's
criticizing the monkeys criticizing the
costumes and they are you know
i mean absolutely not actually begging
to be forgiven
and i thought do they know i'm here
because it was all
around you know what i mean yeah it's
huge drama
um and then i thought well so they don't
know you're here you're not important
it's a costume that's important
that's quite a salutary thing to have
thrown at you unbeknownst by the people
who throw it
[Music]
you